- All right, it looks like
I'm online on Facebook.
Hello, everyone at Facebook.
Sorry, running a little bit late.
If you ask, I'll tell you
about my morning (chuckles).
And it looks like we're
online on YouTube, all right.
So this is good.
As you can imagine, this
has been an interesting
improvisational situation for all of us,
so my apologies for getting started
a little late this morning.
But this is what,
our fourth live stream that we're doing?
And, you know, the whole goal of this is
we have all of these
resources at Khan Academy
that we've been building over the last 10,
actually, 11, 12 years.
And we could've never foreseen
this type of a situation.
You know, Khan Academy,
we've always imagined
the ideal use case being
used in physical classrooms,
so students could learn at
their own time and pace,
give teachers information
on where students are,
and be able to do more
focused interventions
for your classtime for other things.
And also support students
who might not have had
traditional schooling or
if you're in some part
of the world that doesn't have that.
We would've never foreseen this
school closure situation we're in.
But Khan Academy is eerily well-suited
to at least help us work on this.
Because obviously, we have
things from Khan Academy Kids,
for early learners, for math, reading,
writing, social-emotional learning.
And then you get into
the core of Khan Academy,
in math for sure, all the way through
from middle school, high school,
elementary school through college,
English language arts, SAT Practice.
We have the sciences, especially
at the high school level,
AP level, and also several humanities,
American history, et cetera.
And the purpose of this live stream
is to give a little bit
more connectedness to this.
Some people are starting
to call this kind of a
homeroom for us (chuckles).
And like homeroom is in school,
it's the time to talk about anything,
a time, whatever announcements
need to be made, et cetera,
and also just get a
little bit of motivation,
a little bit of energy for the day.
Whether you're a teacher,
you're a parent or a student,
this is just a reminder
that we're all going
through this together,
and we're all gonna
figure it out together.
And so I encourage anyone,
start asking questions on,
whether you're watching
on Facebook or YouTube.
On the streams, I have team members
who are looking at those questions,
who are going to be surfacing them up
on my tablet right over here.
And so I'll know who to
answer questions for.
You know, just a couple
of updates on our side,
we are seeing, and I guess
this isn't super-surprising,
but unusual traffic on Khan Academy.
What I heard from our
team is Monday we saw 50%
larger than expected usage
and then yesterday 80%,
and we're seeing kind of 10X the number
of teacher and student
and parent registrations.
So that's great, that it
sounds like a lot of people
are realizing that this is a
resource that they can turn to.
It's free, it's accessible.
And hopefully, as we
go through this crisis,
folks become more
comfortable with using it.
And I think there's some
ideas we can talk about
of how to complement it.
I do want to say thank
you to Bank of America.
For those of you who
don't know, Khan Academy,
we are not-for-profit.
That means no one owns Khan Academy.
We are not a company.
I don't own Khan Academy.
You own as much of Khan Academy as I do.
And we're funded through philanthropy.
And we love that we're able
to serve everyone right now
as we have this crisis.
But our server costs are
going through the roof.
We're having demand,
more folks to be able to
do things like webinars.
We had a very large parent webinar
that had a thousand
parents on it last night.
And so it's really valuable
that Bank of America stepped up.
You could do a Google search
and read about that press release.
But they stepped up to
really support this,
you can almost call it a relief effort,
that we're trying to up
our game at Khan Academy
to make sure everyone feels
connected and supported.
And expect to see more from us
and our partners like Bank of America.
So thank you to Bank of America for that.
But let me get to,
let me get to some of the questions here.
So the first question is,
"How do I figure out what my
child should be learning?"
So there's a couple of
ways to answer that.
Obviously, as a parent,
you might know what
grade your student's in.
And you might say, "Okay, my
student's a fifth grader."
That might be an
indication that fifth grade
on Khan Academy might be a
really good place to start.
I will put a little asterisk
there, little bit of a caveat.
What we found, even when working
with traditional schools,
is the reason why a lot
of kids have trouble,
and this is especially true in math,
but it's also true in things
like reading and writing,
but especially in math,
they might have trouble
in fifth, sixth, seventh grade math.
It's not because they're not bright.
It's not because the
subject matter is difficult.
It's because as they went through
their academic foundations,
they had some gaps.
They might have been in third grade
when they were learning
multiplication tables.
They just didn't learn their
seven times tables well.
And they got a C on a test,
and then they just moved
on to the next thing.
And so when they see, have to
multiply something by seven
in sixth grade, they just have to spend
a little bit too much cognitive load.
Or their decimals in
fifth grade are a gap.
And so when they see a decimal
in seventh grade, it's a gap.
So one thing we've seen
teachers do to great effect,
there's an amazing
teacher, Tim Vandenberg,
who I was talking to two days ago.
He was telling me how,
with his sixth graders,
he starts them all on
kindergarten on Khan Academy.
And if you know the material,
the students can go through
each course quite quickly.
We have things like Course
Challenges, Unit Tests,
Mastery Challenges that can
accelerate students through it.
That helps them build some
momentum, build some confidence,
get familiarity with the platform,
and then it ensures that
they don't have any gaps.
So he has his students do early learning
and then do the arithmetic
courses on Khan Academy
and the third grade courses.
He'd use those as the foundational
ones and simultaneously
work on the grade-level
course on Khan Academy.
If your student has, for the most part,
been proficient in math,
then I would go straight
to the grade-level course on Khan Academy.
If, since we're already
well into the year,
I would have your child,
and if you're a student, I would have you
take the Course Challenge,
and the Course Challenge
will sample every unit.
And if you take the Course Challenge
and you get an 80 or 90% on it,
keep taking the Course Challenge
and try to get higher and higher scores
until you have mastery in the course.
But if you see there's some gaps
that you're consistently
not getting right,
then those skills,
you can look at those
units that they come from,
and then you can ensure that
you get mastery in those units.
And so that's a way that we're,
you know, we're 3/4 or
80% through the year,
that you can quickly know what you know
and what you don't know and where you need
to actually fill in your gaps.
So that's my personal view of
the quickest way to figure out
where might be the right zone for you.
And the same thing is true
at the high school level.
You know, even high school students,
doesn't hurt starting a little bit behind.
You have more time now,
and make sure you fill in those gaps.
And things like our SAT Practice
that we do with the College
Board, that adapts to you.
So if you start getting questions
of a certain skill wrong,
it'll give you slightly easier ones
or then slightly harder
ones if you get 'em right.
So that's my best advice there.
You know, some people have been asking
for just general tips.
And I was on some of
the morning shows today,
and what I say is make sure
you have some structure today.
As we get more days into
the social distancing,
it's very tempting to stay in your pajamas
and kinda try to work from bed
with the TV running and all that.
That's not going to be good,
and it's not good even for
your own mental health.
It's good to have a pattern.
Wake up in the morning,
just like you would have done for school.
Have your breakfast.
Get ready.
I even heard about some people pretending
like they're on a bus for some period.
I guess that's maybe a form of meditation.
And then break into the schedule.
And we, at Khan Academy,
we've released some schedules
for school closures,
and it's for different schedules
for different age groups
that have different amounts breaks
and things like that in them.
But use those.
You could use those just as they are,
or you can modify them to meet your needs.
But if you have that schedule,
then that also gives you a clearer sense,
as, hey, if I get all
this done by one o'clock
in the afternoon or two
o'clock, I can then relax,
I can then go do other things,
pursue my passions, work on other hobbies.
Ideally, you have a place in the house
that is nice and clean, free of clutter,
where you just associate that with work.
And that spatial association, I think,
will help your productivity.
All right, so we have
Sayed Mohel Rosales asked
"Will Khan Academy always be free?"
Simple answer is yes.
You know our mission statement
is free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
The whole idea about
being a not-for-profit,
there's nothing wrong
with for-profit companies.
Most of my career I'd worked at some form
of a for-profit or an other.
But a for-profit company
at the end of the day,
their bottom line literally, is,
you know maximizing
shareholder value or income,
or things like that.
Nothing wrong with that,
that's how capitalism works.
But a not-for-profit, its
bottom line is its mission,
and our mission is free,
world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And the reason why we set it up
as a not-for-profit you know twelve
years ago I could have never foreseen
this scenario is because there's certain
parts of our market economy where
market forces alone
might not work properly,
or if they did work properly, it might not
lead to the types of outcomes we want.
And you know, I frankly, I
think education and healthcare
are the two areas where you,
you don't want someone's access to it
to be gated by their ability to pay,
or you know, what their
parents do for a living,
or that you know, things like that.
And so that's why Khan Academy is free,
and will always be free.
And it's not, and it's not-for-profit.
It's primarily funded through
philanthropic donations,
So Tada Bevell says,
"Frustrating trying to help
"my college engineering son
with his Internet issues."
"He also needs tutoring in calculus two,
"and physics, any help?"
So depends what the Internet issues are.
I don't have good advice for
if there's connectivity issues.
Maybe the local carrier,
whoever might might be able
to help with some of that.
But if he's taking
calculus two and physics,
we can help there.
Khan Academy has a full,
depending on which college you go to,
first two semesters or three semesters
of college calculus, not just videos.
We have exercises, you get
as much practice as you need.
So I really encourage
your son to get on that.
Make sure he, same advice I
have for the younger students,
take the course challenge.
Understand what he knows and doesn't know,
then he can focus on the units
that he he has some gaps in,
and then if he's able to
get to, say 90% mastery
on our, on our college
calculus, or our Calculus BC,
which is AP, but still a
first-year college course,
I think he'll do great.
We have the same thing
in first year physics.
He could use our AP physics,
which is really college physics, that I,
hopefully will, will help him.
So let's see Alisharova Kilola asks,
"How do I motivate my
little brother to study
"during the quarantine?"
"He really doesn't want to do anything."
And Alisharova, I empathize with you.
I know I have three kids at home.
And the older two, I have to
give them a lot of credit.
11 and and eight years old,
they are really productive.
I think even more productive than me.
Their school's doing a,
you know they're getting
a list of stuff to do every day.
They're, they're connecting on
Hangouts with their teachers
at appropriate times.
So they're fine, but my five-year-old,
I've been having a lot of
difficulty motivating him.
I think he's just getting
used to the circumstances
that we're all finding ourselves in.
We had a good tip from
a homeschooling parent
a couple of days ago on this livestream,
where she said you just
have to stick with it.
At first it's hard,
everyone's getting used
to the same patterns,
but it's just about sticking with it,
maintaining a pattern.
Having consistency, you
know, for very young kids.
I hope none of y'all are,
well I hope you are listening,
but my technique with my
five-year-old sometimes the direct
course of action is not
the ones work on this.
He will resist but if you say,
"Hey, that was really
amazing how many points
"you got yesterday!"
Then you know, kind of
strokes his ego a little bit,
he gets a little excited about that.
Or if you say, "Hey
tell me about that song
"you really like."
And then while, while he
tells you about the song,
I'd kind of open up the
work he needs to do,
handwriting or whatever else.
So, that's one possibility.
But I think, you know,
this is one of those times,
don't beat up yourself.
It's really impressive, as a sibling,
you're trying to help your sibling.
But you know, don't put too
much pressure on yourself.
Do what you can, keep some consistency.
And what the homeschooling
parents are telling us
is that, "Oh it's still the first week
"for most of us, and
so you know it's okay."
"We can we can give all
of ourselves a break,
"and you know."
And this is the other thing
we're gonna probably form some habits
over the next month or two as the
schools are closed and it sounds like, it
in many places they will be closed
to the end of the school year.
We're hearing that in California.
But know we have the whole
summer to continue learning,
to, you know, catch up if
we need to fill in gaps.
And then continue learning.
So as long as people are
able to ramp into the summer
and keep learning during the summer,
I'm not worried that
they're going to be able
to do just fine when schools reopen.
All right, so someone says
"How will Khan Academy
"get me into places like
Stanford University?"
"I understand", oh "I understand.
"a guy who was locked up for 15 years
"used your resources
and got into Stanford."
Okay, so Adam, Adam Bukhari
asked that question.
So I'll first give my disclaimer,
where you go to college,
just does not define you as a human being.
I think too many times in our society,
and a lot of the signals
you get in high school,
and, and when you're young,
from your friends are
like, you're defined.
But you know you try it you're trying to
find your identity and you might be
defined by your test scores,
or where you go to college,
et cetera, et cetera, and you,
your life is far more than that.
Than these test scores, or
where you go to college.
Now, for those of you
who are, you know, you,
there's nothing wrong with wanting to go
to a highly selective University.
I would just say just
don't be attached to it,
as Buddha says the course of all the the
source of all suffering is it you should
always try your best and it's great to
be able to find a college
that will challenge you,
that will put you around other people
that will make you make you better.
My best advice, and I tell this,
you know we have a Lab School downstairs,
and I tell this to the
students about your age
is make sure you really master material.
Don't try to, you know, be, do everything.
Master the core for sure.
You know the the
mathematics, the sciences,
the writing, the humanities.
But make sure you have time
and space for your passions.
You know, you see a lot of students
who, they think they have to do everything
in order to impress other people.
And in some ways the
other people will say,
"That person is just trying to
do everything to impress me."
"Who are they really?"
And we, I've talked to a
lot of admissions officers.
We have some on our advisory
board here at Khan Academy,
and they all tell us we just
want to see authenticity.
For sure, they need to see kids
who they feel confident,
will be able to handle
the academic rigor of their campus.
But they just want to see authenticity.
They want to see curiosity.
They want to see creativity.
And so I think, find your passions.
You have, you know glass half-full,
the school closures, you might
have a little more time now.
This is a great time to
explore your passions,
find solutions for people
in your neighborhood.
There's all sorts of people
who need help right now.
Do it authentically, don't do
it just to get into college.
Say, "Hey, there might be senior citizens
"who can't go to the grocery store."
"Maybe I can drop off the groceries
"out there at their porch."
"Maybe I can turn into a
thing me and my friends
"can volunteer to do that"
If you do it authentically,
then when it's time
to apply to college, and if
you're academically prepared,
you've given it your best shot.
And so that's that's my best advice.
You know the example you
gave, of Jason who was,
for those of you who don't know the story,
this was a young man,
when he was in his teens,
he got arrested for selling marijuana.
He got thirty years in prison in Illinois.
While in prison, his
mother gave him transcripts
of Khan Academy videos
so he could start to learn.
They had no access to the Internet.
He had his sentence shortened to 15 years.
So he gets out in his early 30s,
and then he gets on Khan Academy for real
at the local library, uses
our official SAT practice,
and he's able to kind of catch up,
and he initially said
his local music college.
But he decides that he
wants to apply to Stanford.
And he was able to
transfer, and I met him.
And that's how I even know the story.
So there's some, I don't
say that is the way
that you know, you should go to Stanford.
But I'm saying that as a way
that I think anyone,
if you apply yourself,
you put your best foot forward,
and you're authentic about it.
You know I would say
what's really powerful
about Jason's story is
how authentic he is,
and how much he owns his own history.
And I think that's really
powerful, and people would
be impressed by that.
Let's see Abed Sheik says, "Do
you have any science classes
"for middle school on Khan Academy?"
So obviously that is actually
a gap that we have, officially.
We don't have middle
school science, per se.
With that said, what I will tell you
is I think the high school
biology is completely doable
by a middle school student.
The math prerequisites you
would have already seen
in middle school, things
like negative numbers,
and decimals, and exponents,
and things like that.
And so, and especially
because high school biology,
super interesting right now,
because you'll learn about
viruses, and DNA and RNA.
And you know that's very
relevant to the world we're at,
so I would recommend high school students
to work on the high school,
sorry, middle school students
to work on the high school
biology on Khan Academy.
I think that could keep you busy,
and you'll learn a lot and that's just
a useful, useful skill for life.
All right, so, so Lethal
Hipster, interesting name,
says, "Hi, Khan, how long
have you been teaching?"
Well, depends how you define teaching.
You know I, I've taught in various
formal and informal settings
over over many years.
If I were to go really
far back, the first time
that I realized that I enjoyed tutoring
or teaching was in high school.
It might not surprise people,
but I was the president of the math club.
I assure you, it was cooler
than you might imagine,
and as part of that we had,
we used to tutor a lot of our,
we had free tutoring for
everyone at our school.
And I saw over and over
again that students,
my friends who thought
they weren't good at math,
if they just had a
little bit of attention,
a little bit of being able
to fill in their gaps,
then all of a sudden were like,
"Wait, this isn't so bad."
And, and then they were,
they were off to the races.
And so that's what first
stuck in my head of
the reason why people are held back
isn't because of their ability,
it's because of these gaps.
And they just need a little bit of
personalization, so to
speak, to fill in those gaps.
Then in college I, I did some,
actually I taught at the,
there's a local school district
in Brookline, Massachusetts
and they had lost funding
for some of their classes.
And so they were looking
for volunteer teachers.
So when I was in college
it was actually myself,
and my roommate, who's
named Shantanu Sinha,
and he was actually the first
president of Khan Academy.
We used to go volunteer teach
at Brookline Devotion School.
This was in Brookline, Massachusetts
in middle school students.
And then later in college
I actually was doing
some test flight, test
prep stuff for for folks
like Princeton Review.
And then my career took
a completely different,
I went into tech, et cetera, et cetera.
But I was always fascinated
by this whole teaching side.
And so when my cousins,
in 2004, needed help,
I was like, "Hey can I tutor you?"
"'Cause I just love,
it's just fun to be able
"to connect with people."
"I love the subject matter."
And then that's kind of how I got started
on this this Khan Academy adventure.
That was about 16 years ago.
Yesterday someone commented
about how old I look,
and so that's why.
(laughs)
Someone is asking, Andy says
"Hey Sal, it's 8:17 AM here,
"and I'm about to live with
"schedules that you planned."
"Thank you so much!"
Andy, great news!
And yeah, my apologies.
I know these livestreams conflict
with the same schedules that we publish,
and it's hard.
'Cause those schedules are
whatever time zone you're on,
and obviously this live
stream is happening
at different times, depending
on what time zone you are in.
But I'm glad you're using the schedules.
And we are going to look
for more ways to support
those schedules and we
can get you support.
See, it says "How can I
learn personal finance
at Khan Academy?"
You could literally look at our menus.
There's a course menu when
you go to the top left.
And Finance and Personal Finance
are sections on Khan Academy.
Those don't have the exercises
the way that math and other subjects do.
But there's a lot of videos there,
and I think if you look at those videos,
and especially if if I'm
working through a problem,
you pause and you try
to do it on your own.
You'll be surprised how
much personal finance
you might learn.
And I'm happy to answer actually
any personal finance
questions if anyone has any.
And I know this is a time that might be
stressing folks' finances, so I'm or maybe
they're having questions
about the stock market,
and my, you know my old life I used to be
an investment analyst.
So I don't mind answering
questions about that.
Okay so Christine Priti,
"Will you be adding
more courses, et cetera
"if schools stay closed
for a longer time?"
A great question Christine.
You know we, we're looking
to do anything and everything
necessary to be able to support folks
through this school closure situation.
It looks like they
will be closed and you know in many
places through the end of the year.
We're talking, you know
everything we do is
philanthropically funded, so
you know we talked earlier
about the the gap we have
in middle school science.
I would love nothing more
than to be able to create
some middle school science
content on Khan Academy.
We need to find philanthropists.
Small and large philanthropists,
every donation counts.
So that we can start
hiring up a team of folks
who can start helping build that content.
You know a lot of time I get
disproportionate credit for Khan Academy
'cause I make a lot of the videos.
And you know I'm kind of the mascot,
for better or for worse.
I'm not so pleasant of a mascot.
but there's a lot of
people behind the scenes.
We have over 200 employees
who have salaries
that we need to be able to
pay so that they can do their work.
Most of these people
have taken salary cuts
from what they could be doing
in the for-profit sector
because they're so passionate
about this mission.
And on the content side
I have a ton of support
from people, oftentimes
with PhDs in the subject,
who are curating what the,
what the sequence should be,
how we cover the standards,
writing these thousands of items
that we have to write per course,
getting it vetted with
outside third parties.
So there's a lot of work that
goes on behind the scenes
for those courses, but
I hope that we can add
more and more courses,
especially if it looks like this,
this crisis continues for, you know
beyond what we're thinking right now.
So let's see, high school
seniors are stressed
about school closures, no
prom, no graduation ceremony,
what advice do you have for them?
So I'm, I'm, I don't know how all of this
is going to play out,
and you know there's some part of it
that's not so great.
That you're, you, you might
miss out on some of these,
whatever you want to call them,
rites of, rites of passage.
What I would say to you is you
and your generation,
especially those of you
who are high school juniors
and seniors right now,
this is going to define your generation.
You know when you're my age,
y'all are gonna sit around
the table and reminisce about 2020.
"Remember that, remember coronavirus?"
"Remember what was special
about our generation?"
And I think that actually
will, in many ways,
form deeper bonds than you know,
all of the other things
that you might have done
in the past.
And I think there's ways
that you can still have those experiences.
Let's say you graduate.
Let's say we're still in
this, in this quarantine,
or stay at home policy
and so you're not able
to get those formal ceremonies.
Maybe they can happen in
the fall, once ought we
surface from this.
Or at a later date, and that,
that could be fun too.
You know, I'm supposed to be
involved with a few graduations
earlier this summer, and yeah I'm assuming
they might not happen.
But the, I hope they eventually happen
so that those students can get
their proper congratulations
for what they've done,
so, so it'll all be,
it'll all be good at the end.
So I wouldn't worry about it too much.
Take care of yourself more than anything,
and I think it'll all, it'll all work out.
So let's see other questions here.
Lisa Moore says, "So
homeschooling parent here."
"Can confirm it, it does get better."
"The routine becomes normal."
"Important to keep a routine
of sorts, and you're right."
"Ditch the PJ 24/7 habit, it's
harder to break later on."
Okay, so reinforcement,
change out of your pajamas,
patience, and perception.
Know yourself, know your kid.
Great advice, Lisa thank you for that.
You know I just got news
from, I just got news from,
from our team here that,
you know our partners,
Bank of America, you know
we had that earlier question
about financial literacy?
They were the ones that have funded
that financial literacy
work and career work
we have on Khan Academy
over the last seven years.
And especially for many of
y'all who are teenagers,
or in your early 20s we
have a ton of content,
not just on financial literacy,
but different career paths
and how to navigate them,
and and the pros and cons and,
and the financial stresses,
or benefits of different careers.
And so the bank has been
instrumental in funding all of that
over the last seven years,
And as I mentioned, they
have been the first company
to step up, over,
literally over the weekend
when they realized that we needed support
as a non-profit.
They step up and it looks like
they just announced a
hundred million dollars
of support to non-profits worldwide.
So that's a huge deal, you know.
I know the folks at the bank for a while.
Folks like and Anne Finucane,
and Meredith, and Michelle,
and you know I've just been
inspired by their willingness
to step up and help the
world, as just as human beings
and I think that is just
representative of the whole,
of the whole bank.
Let's see, any other questions?
So there's more questions coming in,
we're close to time.
Maybe I could do one
more question, but, well,
you know I'll just finish
up with a standard message.
This is a time that is
challenging for all of us.
But you know the point of this livestream
is to remind all of us that
we're in this together.
As I've said in previous live streams,
this is actually something
that I really enjoy connecting
with all of y'all because I've been
penned up in my house for this week.
And so I think it's, as all
of us are navigating this,
as long as we stay connected,
as long as we keep learning,
and as long as we recognize that this is
all gonna, this is all
gonna sort itself out.
Over time, it's going to
be a blip in our life.
It's going to be, make for great stories
to tell our children and our grandchildren
how we all stepped up,
and dealt with this,
and supported each other
in this together.
I'll also just give a
public health announcement.
I really do encourage people to take
the social distance seriously.
I posted a video over the weekend,
and I think you do a search for like
Khan Academy and COVID,
or something like that
it'll tell you how,
you know, these things grow,
and the reported cases are probably,
are for sure understating
the actual cases out there.
Because not everyone's tested.
Not everyone has had symptoms.
And so you might be carrying it,
and you might be lucky and
not have so much symptoms,
especially if you're young.
But if you want to protect your parents
and your grandparents,
do your best to keep a social distance.
That's the best way that this looks.
The sooner that everyone does that,
the quicker that we will get through this,
and that the lower chance we have
of overwhelming our healthcare system.
So thank you everyone,
it's, it's a real treat
to be able to do this with you.
Thanks for joining in.
And, you know, get on
Khan Academy and learn,
and use the schedules, and
tell everyone about it as well.
I think there's still a lot
of parents and students,
who are feeling a little
lost and and so the
more that